it was part of a conspiracy all these
things were planned
you don't know that you proud of living
in a country where child killers are
get presidential pardons we will never
pardon
anyone who is doing something wrong the
government of sri lanka has been
strongly criticized that the un human
rights council
which warned of a deteriorating
situation in the country
the erosion of judicial independence and
the increased marginalization of
minorities
my guest this week is gianna colombagi
secretary to sri lanka's foreign
ministry
is there any chance at all that his
government will take the criticism
seriously and finally do something about
[Music]
them
[Music]
giannath columba gay welcome to conflict
zone
in the last few days the un human rights
council passed a landmark resolution
highlighting your government's failure
to ensure accountability for human
rights violations
and mandating you and investigators to
collect and preserve data
that can be used in future judicial
proceedings
they did that mr secretary because of
your abject failure to do it for
yourselves and because of the
worsening human rights climate in your
country
aren't you ashamed of that well
tim let me say the world war ended 78
years
later earlier and we still
see the residual effects on the
environment on the physical things
and the good friday agreement was in
1998
and there are 116 walls which which is
called peace wall still
we're not talking about northern ireland
mr secretary we're talking about we're
talking about
sri lanka and your failure to ensure
accountability for human rights
violations
which you've already denied which you've
denied in other interviews
no we had a war for one more one
generation and it takes time
to heal a completely war and it was a
devastating war it was a brutal war
right and we finished the war in 2009
and between 2009
and 2015 92 percent of the land
occupied by the military were released
295 000
people who were used as a human shield
were reintegrated and resettled into the
community
twelve thousand i i i understand i
understand
all that mr secretary but your your
foreign minister
has already denied the accusations of
serious human rights violations
you put up the inevitable barrage of
denials and accusations of western bias
do you really think that the rest of the
world is so stupid that they're going to
immediately accept those denials in the
face of overwhelming
documented evidence of your current
human rights abuses i'm not talking
about
those just in the past i'm talking about
continuing
human rights abuses in your country
where are these documents can we have a
look at these documents that you are
referring to
the un has sent them to you the un has
sent them to you
numerous times you read them in the in
the
resolution at the human rights council
so it's a little strange for you to
pretend that you haven't seen them
no we have seen this document prepared
by the human rights commissioner that's
okay
right but you know there had been five
uh i mean from 2012 2013 2014
and now 2021 so every time
this government comes to power there is
a resolution from the united nations
human rights council
right is that fair i think we have to
ask back the human right
council whether that is fair
to account for your actions isn't it mr
secretary
your foreign minister your foreign
minister called the accusations false
and complained that the whole resolution
was politically motivated
well more than 40 countries co-sponsored
this resolution
22 voted for it 14 abstained only 11
against
you're rapidly losing international
support and credibility and the votes
prove it
tim who are these 40 countries 35
countries are in europe
right then outside the europe is canada
america england
malawi and solemn martial island so 35
white countries got together and make
this an
unsubstantiated accusation allegation
so this is nothing to do with human
rights in sri lanka oh so
so they're automatic so they're
automatically wrong even your good
friend
india who you lobbied incessantly to
vote against the resolution
they abstained they weren't buying your
denials either were they
but look at what the in what the
statement made by the indian permanent
representative in the beginning
they said this kind of country specific
resolutions are wrong
and then they said they abstained that
is their policy that yes
the real question from all this mr
secretary is
do you want to be taken seriously on the
international stage
or just dismissed as one more serial
human rights abuser
protected by a small gang of other
abusers
we want to be taken very seriously in
the international community
and no other country or entity is more
interested than sri lanka to find a
lasting solution to the residual issues
that we have
in sri lanka because we are a small
country small population
and the harmony and peace is of
critically important for us
more than anyone else but it has to
evolve within us no one can force
reconciliation here let's um you say you
want uh
to heal wounds and you want
reconciliation
but let's take the un's charge of you
marginalizing minorities one of the
worst examples has been your instruction
to cremate the bodies of covet victims
something that you knew would be
deeply hurtful to your muslim community
and other minorities
you've now retracted this order but you
claimed in a recent interview
that you simply followed the science and
that the world health organization
had originally instructed all covet
bodies should be cremated
that statement of yours was completely
untrue wasn't it they never said
anything of the kind
well if you look at the world health
organization initial
they said cremation of all kovid bodies
it is there
of course no they didn't mr secretary
they didn't
what date what date was that when they
don't have the details now but i will
come back to you on this
and then later on they changed that to
criteria the burial is permitted
and now that question is behind us team
we have buried 69
i know you wanted to change the subject
but you told them you made a statement
that was blatantly false
since march last year the who made it
clear that the burial of covet victims
was perfectly acceptable its statement
called it a common myth that persons
who've died of communicable disease
should be cremated but this is not true
cremation is a matter of cultural choice
and available resources to date there is
no evidence
of persons having become infected from
exposure to the bodies
of covet 19 victims that was march
20th last year but you ignored all that
and your government kept on ordering the
cremation of covet victims
despite knowing that this would cause
untold pain and distress
so your excuse that the world health
organization said this
falls apart it just simply doesn't
conform to the facts mr secretary
well it was never a political decision
it was always
a health and science decision only thing
yes we did fight against the decision to
change that
track but it took some time and we do
understand that was not the best thing
to do we
did hurt the sentiments of a population
or a community in sri lanka
that is not the best thing we could do
yes we do understand
i'm not arguing against that but now we
have corrected it and we have moved on
69 bodies have
already been buried and now it's behind
us we took time
talking of marginalizing minorities it
turns out that your own president has
indulged in some pretty inflammatory
rhetoric over the last year hasn't he
on november the 18th he talked about
legitimate fears that the sinhala race
our religion national resources and the
heritage would be
threatened with destruction in the face
of various local and foreign forces
and ideologues that support separatism
extremism
and terrorism this was a clear dog
whistle to his supporters
to be on their guard against muslims and
other minorities wasn't it this wasn't a
call for national unity
he was blatantly pressing the fear
button knowing full well
that it would stoke the kind of
discrimination and disharmony
that you claim to be fighting tim you
wait and see
there is a lot of evidence surfacing
regarding the eastern bombing easter
bombing was the single most devastating
act
act of terrorism which took place in
this country
nearly 270 christians foreigners
and three hotels and three churches were
bombed by
the extremists you wait and see this
that was 2019.
that was 2019 and everybody everybody
admits
there's no argument there that this was
a terrible attack
i'm talking about what your president
said november the 18th last year
stoking the fires of intercommunal
hatred
as i said this wasn't a call for
national unity he was pressing
the fear button telling people to be
afraid of the minorities
quite clear from what he said i think in
the same statement
if i remember right he made it very
clear
that he is the president for all
communities all people
in this country although he was elected
by the sinhala majority
so you take one portion of that and
argue but i can argue back
it is not what the president meant
president has been very focal on
maintaining harmony but on the back of
the election that's what he
said mr secretary whether or not he
meant it it's
it's what he said it's exactly what he
said he said i am the president
and i'm the president for all people of
this country so there was no racial uh
connotation in that it was contradicted
by what it was contradicted by what he
said
about national resources and heritage
sinhala heritage
will be threatened with destruction but
mr secretary
it's it's been threatened for the last
five six hundred years from time to time
yes it has been
yes and that's making people more and
more fearful
of minorities let's look at your country
let's look at your anti-terrorism
regulations which have so upset
the un and human rights groups the
international commission of jurists has
consistently called for the repeal of
this act
which has been used it says to
arbitrarily detain suspects for months
and often years without charge or trial
why do you keep such repressive laws in
place
tim from 2015 to 2019 there was a
discussion of a counterterrorism bill
the unity government which was formed by
coalition of the main two political
parties with the support of eu with the
support of u.s and other countries
drafted the counterterrorism proposal
that is the new act
but they could not just do it right so
there are issues
in our pta we do accept that we need to
revisit our pta
we do accept that this long term un
on revisiting it you've said that sri
lanka has
a very democratic regime no repression
whatsoever these are your words
but your anti-terrorist laws make a
nonsense of that
what place does arbitrary detention
without charge or trial have in a
democratic
country if that's what you are that's
what you claim to be well
this is why i said we need to revisit
the prevention of terrorism act and we
need to draw lessons from the best
practices internationally
and we are going to do that team
meanwhile you're passing
you're passing new repressive
legislation march the 12th this year
your so-called de-radicalization
regulations
these allow for arbitrary administrative
detention of people
for up to two years without trial
this is a hallmark of repression
arbitrary detention without trial
you say you're working on it that you
keep passing new regulations that are
just as repressive as the old ones
well imagine the situation if we did not
have the pta
after the 19th uh the 2019 easter
bombing
we would not have been able to do
anything in this country it would have
been utter chaos
maybe somebody wanted our country to be
a chaotic
so i am saying the pta is in the in the
topic of discussion
and we are determined to revisit and we
are determined to amend and also the
long-term detain is
we need to find a solution to that we do
agree that it is wrong
without charge to keep someone for a
very long period
president already given directives to
the attorney general to find a solution
to this
meanwhile these regulations are in
blatant violation of your international
legal obligations and they violate
article 13 of the sri lankan
constitution
do you know what that article says
well i don't have a copy right now but
well it what it says if i
can remind you is that it guarantees
freedom
from arbitrary arrest detention and
punishment
so you're breaking your own constitution
with these new
regulations would you keep the term
arbitrary
term arbitrary doesn't come here tim in
the beginning i
requested you please wait for another
few weeks and you will come out
i mean we the investigators will come
out with the real picture
and then the whole world will agree what
has gone
underneath we have only seen the tip of
the iceberg on the
easter bombing but there is a whole heap
of things which has happened before that
and it is happening even now so things
will come out
in due course and just pta we will
revisit
but there will be new legislation
introduced to the country
for the protection of human dignity for
the social harmony
well that would that would that would
make a change wouldn't it because
let's look at um you know the way you've
been handling
um trials and commissions the main
reason
the human rights council voted against
you was that you've disrupted
and impeded efforts to bring justice and
accountability
for all sides in the civil war that's
the un
saying that they accuse you of him of
entrenching
impunity for grave human rights
violations
and abuses by all sides this is now one
of the hallmarks of your state isn't it
well it does nothing to do as you say
because if you remember
if you recall from 2009 to 2015 there
were three commissions appointed to find
out the way forward but unfortunately
after 2015 none of these commissions
could continue
function and now the president has
appointed a commission of inquiry
with this retire with the supreme court
judge maintaining
ethnicity balance maintaining gender
balance
in order to find answers to whether
there are any issues regarding
accountability
whether there are any issues regarding
missing person
so give us time we need we have given
them a time we have given them
you you've had time to disrupt and
impede the existing um
judicial processes um this obstruction
says the u.n has taken the form of
actually
arresting some of the war crimes
investigators and threatening others
the u.n said one former chief of the
criminal investigation division who led
investigations
into several key human rights cases was
himself
arrested and another nishantha silva
from the same division
had to leave sri lanka because of
threats immediately
after the last presidential election and
you tell me that's the way a democracy
which you claim to have
pursues justice doesn't look like it
does it
well everything is in the media
everything is in front of the commission
a police inspector can leave to another
country without taking approval within
less than 12 hours
he doesn't have to be threatened he this
this particular
thing was stressful he says he was
threatened
he was not threatened it was part of a
conspiracy all these things were planned
they were probably given lots of money
to do these things
all these things you don't know that you
don't know that mr secretary that's
that's the story
i'm saying the inquiries are coming out
with all these things that is why i said
it takes time to come out with the truth
in january
in january last year your presidential
commission
investigating so-called political
victimization of public officials
began intervening to halt prosecutions
including those of two former navy
officers charged in relation
to the disappearance of 11 people in
2008
and 2009. this intervening
in judicial proceedings doesn't inspire
public confidence does it
it's also this commission has intervened
in favor of military intelligence
officers
uh interfered in other trials including
by withholding documentary evidence
threatening prosecutors
with legal action running parallel and
contradictory examinations
all these are accusations by the united
nations in other words you've been
destroying
any chance of a proper trial and
bringing proper
accountability you've allowed suspects
to go free
you're not interested in the truth i
will not comment on a presidential
commission and that matter is before the
court in the country
there is a petition against that
commission so i am not in a position to
comment on anything on that
presidential commission on political
victimization
because it is a matter before the courts
well you may not want to comment on that
the fact is
that uh you have been freeing guilty
people
in march last year the president
pardoned a soldier
convicted of massacring eight civilians
including children human rights watch
said it showed your government's
disregard
for justice for the worst abuses mr
secretary
you pardon child killers the other
no limits to which you won't sink you
a child killer convicted child killer
gets a presidential pilot
pardon what kind of country are you
living in
well tim do you know that 12 500
x ltt combatants were pardoned similarly
without any trial
did you know that do you know 459 child
soldiers as young as
10 were not even considered as
combatants but considered as victims
of war and sent back to school to study
with books and school bags and shoes
right so we have done both right so i
can't argue
i can't comment on a decision made by
the president to pardon
a person and the previous regime also
pardoned
ltte hardcore terrorists so these are
things happening
so it is not only one side i come back
to this you proud of living in a country
where child
killers are get presidential pardons you
can't sing much longer than that
you're not you're not holding your armed
forces accountable the message
that that sends to your armed forces is
basically you can get away with anything
can't you
if you can kill children if you can kill
children in cold blood you can get away
with anything
it is never like that we will never
pardon anyone who is doing something
wrong
and the president is determined to make
things right and make someone
accountable if
a person has done anything wrong against
the law a president will never ever
take the side of a criminal never ever
no just give him a presidential pardon
um mr secretary your civil war
is presidential pardons are there in the
world now
we're not talking about the rest of the
world we're talking about sri lanka but
why why why you only sri lanka why you
only you talk about one person
you don't represent the rest of the
world i talk to the rest of the world
about what they do i'll be talking to
you about what sri lanka does
is hypocrisy i mean you are talking
about one person
it's asking you to account for the
actions of your government it's as
simple as that no at least
just one person and we have pardoned 12
500.
mr secretary your civil war may have
ended more than 12 years ago
but since your government isn't
interested in accountability thousands
of family members from all communities
are still seeking justice
and truth about the fate of their loved
ones
and your response to date has been to
send state agents
to harris and intimidate human rights
defenders
lawyers journalists social actors and
victims of human rights
abuses how does how helpful is that
to your declared aim of bringing
reconciliation
and accountability to your country how
helpful
there is there is a office of missing
person
established according to the thirty
slash one in 2015
and this office is empowered
appointments
made budgetary allocations give a given
action plan is requested and they have
to produce results
i'm asking you about the harassment i'm
asking you about the harassment your
police have continually
your police have continually harassed a
member of the adversary
advocacy group mothers of the
disappeared
one of them whose son was disappeared in
2009 told human rights watch
that officers of the criminal
investigation department continually
question her about who's going to
meetings who's going to give testimony
in geneva what are they going to say
what business is that of your criminal
investigation division
well if there is a issue with the person
they can always complain to the police
and they can seek redress from the
judiciary
and our judiciary is very independent
and in these so-called
areas is mostly it is their own natives
who are the judges
so this these are only accusations very
conveniently made without any substance
why don't they make a complaint to the
police they can make a complaint to the
president they can make a complaint to
the
inspector general of police and they can
make judiciary proceeding without doing
that
you just complain and then you mention
about human rights defenders
we know most of the human rights
defenders are
receiving money from the west and we
know the bank accounts we know how much
money has come and gone
right so these are not bona fide human
rights defenders they are playing to the
tune of someone
one of them you've just smeared the
whole lot of them in one sentence is
that
really what you want to do you don't
have enough to smear
and to smear a whole raft of your
society
defending human rights we are
very much interested in human rights no
one else is interested in human rights
than sri lankans and sri lanka that is
the fact
no one is interested about human rights
and reconciliation than sri lankans in
sri lanka
your human rights record is criticized
you deny everything
mr secretary the u.n insists that you
address these criticisms some of which
we've
talked about during this interview and
it also holds out the
threat that member states might start
applying
targeted sanctions asset freezes and
travel bans against your state officials
and others credibly alleged to have been
involved in human rights violations
are you ready for that well you know if
individual countries have a separate
agenda
uh not necessarily human rights but
using human right as a weapon
there is very little we can do but let's
wait and see
i mean we also have support from large
number of countries it was evident in
the human rights commission proceedings
in the beginning when the report was
submitted 21 countries
spoke against the human rights
commissioner's report and in the
proceeding discussions they have a lot
of opposition to this
of course the voting they got 22 but
even they got one vote less than
the last time 2014 and they have a large
number of absentees that is 14.
so this world is divided so you are i
mean sometimes very
very very quickly as we're running out
of time are you going to take note of
these criticisms
or are you going to stick to your
blanket denials which no one believes
whether we are tonight or not we are
going to continue with the pledges that
we have made to the international
community to find
answers for reconciliation missing
persons
we are going to an accountability we are
going to find
answers through a domestic mechanism as
quickly as we can
because we don't want to shed away from
the responsibility to the international
community
more than that to the people of this
country we've run out of time jayanath
kalambaggi thank you very much for being
on conflict zone
thank you
[Music]
you